nowadays you see a bunch of portable
battery packs from Big to small but the
Delta II is not just a battery when
ecoflow wanted to send this thing out to
me I have to say I was a bit hesitant
but after looking into the specs and
then using it for a bunch of different
tasks I wish I had one of these years
ago and I'm happy to partner with them
and share my experience along with why
the Delta II solar generator really
stands out and it is so nice to have
first things first if you're gonna spend
the money you want to make sure that
this thing lasts and unlike most
portable battery stations that are rated
for 500 Cycles the Delta II is rated for
three thousand six times longer than the
average competitor now that is because
it uses the same type of LPF Battery
Technology as Tesla does so even if you
use it once a day every day it will last
for 10 years which is incredible and
that is what I care about if you're
buying something like this and this
thing is is powerful not only can It
support up to 15 devices it can output
1800 watts standard and top of that you
can toggle the X boost in the app to go
up to 2 200 Watts we'll talk about the
app in a bit it is really awesome and as
a search of 2700 Watts if something
spikes now I've used other battery packs
before I've used some inverters and then
it just I had a hard time because I was
working on the playground and then I
didn't have enough power to do like some
of my power tools but this thing has no
issues at all and on the front not only
do we have two USB type-cs they're both
100 Watts so you can fast charge your
MacBooks and still have two ports so
that's very powerful we have some
standard USBS and then fast charging
cable ones as well and then on the back
this is crazy we have six full power out
left two of these have ground slots in
here that's crazy you have a separate
toggle to turn that on and off we also
have regular outputs right here the
little Barrel plug with adapters and
then we have a 12 volt one like you
typically have in your car for travel
accessories so that is great and the
ports above we have the charging port we
have a little breaker switch and then we
have the solar connector which I'll talk
about with the Delta II you can run over
90 percent of your appliances and when
we went camping the first thing that we
did is we made waffles with this thing
and those take a lot of power and
typically I would have to do it inside
my trailer if I had hookups but we
didn't have hookups here so I wouldn't
be able to anyways and our table was
really far away from the campground
we're at and I was able to grab this
thing and go out and do that with my
kids it was awesome now during that trip
we did a lot of things we used a coffee
maker we use this bug zapper which was
really convenient just be able to have
anything any of those kind of things
anywhere we're at and with that we
actually boiled water with a kettle and
those things take so much power you
would not be able to do that but with
this thing we could and this thing's not
just for camping I found a bunch of uses
for it at my house for example my kid
left my tractor lights on so the battery
died and I have that about 150 feet away
from my garage so I'd have to run
multiple extensions or have to push it
back to my house instead I grabbed this
thing I brought it over I plugged in a
little battery charger and charged it
right up it was super convenient and
this thing is surprisingly light for the
capacity it's 27 pounds when I took it
out of the box I was really surprised by
how lightweight it was and because of
that I started taking it more places for
example we went to the beach and I had
my inflator with me and I think I need
to charge up the battery so I literally
just grabbed it with me brought it down
plugged it in had no problems at all so
it's super convenient for whatever
you're doing now this thing lasts a
surprisingly long time inside of here we
have a thousand and 24 watt hour battery
uh this one is 74. this one is 11. so
it's quite large and when we have had it
hooked up to the trailer it was powering
the outlets given the extra boost of
wattage keeping the main batteries
powered up which is great because those
things die super quickly you don't want
to scale them up and down which with
this technology you can drain all the
way and kick it back up and I was able
to charge it up during the day and then
run it during the day and at night it
was great now for 1024 isn't enough you
can actually buy this separate battery
that doesn't have any connections it
literally plugs right into the side and
gives you double the battery 2048
8 watt hour so that is great for when
you're gonna be out for multiple days
you can't charge there's a solution for
that or you just need a lot more
capacity there's a little storage
compartment up top to store all of your
cables so that is very nice and if you
actually need more they have a bigger
version that will give you up to
3040. now what is absolutely crazy is
the charging time this thing charges
about seven times faster than the
average competitor which is crazy now
this guy right here this tiny thing
takes an hour and 20 minutes to be fully
charged and that's 11 Watt hours this
1024 Watt hours also takes an hour and
20 minutes to get fully charged from
zero to a hundred and if you're charging
just to 80 percent it only takes 50
minutes which is incredible so if you're
getting ready to go camping something
else you plug it in by the time you got
everything loaded set up it is fully
charged and that is just so convenient
from a standard outlet just plug it in
now what's even cooler is the fact that
you can get one of their solar panels
and this is the best solar panel I've
ever used I've used most multiples and
this thing can actually charge it up in
about five to six hours and then you can
use it the rest of the day and at night
if you have full Sunshine which is
exactly what we did when we went camping
we had no power hookups and then if you
have two of these with extra battery you
can have it up 10 12 hours in full sun
and then be using it all night or even
using it as it's charging it is so
awesome so this solar panel is crazy
crazy impressive I didn't think it's
gonna be so cool first off it's not that
heavy fits into this small package I
know some of it might be off screen
because I have a tight shot but check
out how insanely thin this is these
panels are made to be crazy durable uh
they're super super thin they're rigid
you can set it up and angle it but not
only does it have cells on one side it
actually has cells on the back side as
well so that it will catch more energy
that bounces off of you know the Conch
concrete grasses and as efficient but it
still catches some depending on your
material it is so so cool and it folds
into a setup like this so I was
literally charging this thing completely
for free and then using all of that
pattern that turns into the Delta II
solar generator this one is the 220 watt
version they also have higher capacities
if you want to charge faster so that is
really sweet to have now the other
unique thing is how smart this thing is
at first I was like why do I really need
that for a battery but it's actually
extremely handy now the first thing you
do is scan the QR code on it and that
brings it to the App Store you can
download the app so that was very easy
and then you can actually connect over
Bluetooth it has Bluetooth and Wi-Fi and
I was also like why do you need both
sounds kind of weird but it is awesome
so with Bluetooth when I went out
camping we obviously didn't have any
Wi-Fi so I could connect and control it
but then when you're at home if you have
it plugged in you're powering something
you can actually just access it from
anywhere be able to control it so let's
go ahead and open up the app here right
now it's disconnected let me go ahead
and turn it on bam it connected
instantly I'm gonna click into it and uh
right now we have 62 hours of power
available if it's just sitting there
that's only at 22 percent charge uh here
we see the input if we were charging it
with AC or solar like I did before and
then for output you can actually control
both the 12 volt DC outputs
um the USBs separately and the AC now
why would you want to do that first I'm
like why isn't just on all the time well
one you guys see that follow circuits
are running it uses more power but two
when I was in the trailer it was night
time already I had it plugged in I saw
that my trailer batteries were
completely full so there's no reason to
keep this turned on and running power to
so I just clicked on it turned that off
and Bam it is done and then this thing
can go to sleep and I have more power
left for the next day same thing for if
you're charging up another device is so
nice to have that now with that you have
access to a lot of settings you can
control your AC charging speed just in
case you're limited for you know
whatever reasons for a car input which
is great to charge this thing if you're
driving somewhere you literally plug it
in and you're pretty much getting free
Power a little bit more load in the
alternator but it's not much and you can
charge this thing up which is awesome
you can adjust that from 8 amps down to
four if your car can't give you as much
power and then if you have a smart
generator which they sell which will
actually connect and charge it up you
can control that and you can turn on
your X boost frequency and you can
actually control how how much you wanted
to discharge to if you don't drain all
the way or charge up to if you want to
give it absolutely insane battery life
if you know standard is not enough
there's a lot more settings here you can
update the firmware so it's just so nice
to have all of that at your phone uh no
matter if you're close to it or really
far away over Wi-Fi so with that said
this thing is awesome and I wish that I
had it years ago would have saved me a
lot of headaches trying to use inverters
not have enough power and it's just so
so convenient to have with that fast
charging and all the other capabilities
so the Delta II is not just a battery
but it's an essential Home Appliance
whether for daily home use outdoor or
travel use so it's a handy and
eco-friendly power solution for your
family anytime and anywhere so go ahead
and head down to the link in the video
description to check out all of
ecoflow's Green Energy Solutions like
this Delta II especially when you power
it with the solar generator free
electricity that is awesome you can
check out their other products and
accessories so click that Circle above
if you guys want to subscribe check out
one of those videos right over there
there's been Max and I'll see you in the
next video
[Music]